I'm oh you're mowing dirt let's go he's
fed the homeworks checked I've done my
job I'm taking a break why is he mowing
your dirt patch oh yeah he's paying me
hourly I'm showing him how the world
works your work you get paid you drink
are you drinking alcohol started there's
still away you can talk to them you
can't do that she's gone the board isn't
that what you're supposed to do with it
I yesterday you said it was just a game
if we play the game and nothing happens
then I'll never bring it up again well I
hope you don't mind me coming by I got
your address from this letter that you
wrote my wife Amy and I believe in the
lost art of letter writing I always
wondered why you kept in touch after
everything you know one of those useless
machines they used to make a skull on
MRI and afterward any of those left the
doctor's would have been able to run the
cyst in my wife's brain before she died
instead a half tours and she'd had been
the one who sitting here listening to
this baymax I didn't know you were still
active I heard a sound of distress what
seems to be the trouble oh I just
stubbed my toe a little I'm fine on a
scale of 1 to 10 how would you rate your
pain zero I'm okay really thanks you can
shrink now does it hurt when i touch it
that's a cake no notes that team you
guys
how you have fallen you think